I'm talking about doing shocking things
and of course you dented Li in in your
husband who the sob yeah you went 12 I
what husband we've all been around the
block
Jonah this break Edwards yes well what a
legend you guys were married teacher why
you kidding oh my gosh Google the other
guests
she's such a legend and he's such
amazing with a legendary combination to
that lovely guy 442 II Wow
a be the only person I've refined there
hook on him Sammy Watson you know they
wrote a book Oh God can you guys go away
from me yeah Phil yeah that's crazy yeah
oh yeah I think maybe most of the
audience know he did all the great Pink
Panther movies he did at breakfast at
tiffany's and Rajasthan and unten and
those kind of movies but no I had to go
topless fur but it was very legitimate
and I had it took ten years super
legitimate it was legitimate Lee in the
script is what I'm saying no yes
very legitimate don't see a ten-time
yeah you love it is all about it's a
real take off on Hollywood it's a very
funny sob sob is yeah oh and you don't I
don't know I'm sorry about God but what
will fed on our wedding night I feel the
way two people were the people who know
they were just telling you don't do this
you're Julia no no no I mean I'd done an
awful lot by then and I had as I say it
took ten years to get the movie made so
I had ten years to think about it and it
was in the script and quite as I say
legitimate and it just can be cold in
the studio didn't you find that oh yeah
and it's a lot worse when it's cold for
us then
chills help ladies no I don't think so
no I mean goosebumps don't look
particularly good on camera I guess not
just turns to me and he goes Jonah Jonah
Bobo no banana fanna fo fona me mama
Mona Joan my singer I can't
compete with this